their women are very good in high school
then they go to college they're very
good in college they nail their damn
grades they do their studying to get
their AIDS and they and they ace their
LSAT so they're smart too
then they go off to do their articling
and they're really really good at it
and then they get offered an associate
position and they're really really good
at it and then by the time they're 30
they make partner and let's say they're
in high-pressure high-paying jobs two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year three hundred thousand dollars a
year five hundred dollars an hour okay
what's your life like you work all the
time period 70 hours a week 75 hours a
week flat out and you don't get to make
any mistakes and if your client calls
you at 3:00 in the morning on Monday on
Sunday you say I'm really glad to hear
you hear from you because if you don't
there's some hot law firm in New York
that will take your client from you at a
moment's notice and the client is paying
you whatever the firm 750 dollars an
hour of which maybe you get 350 and what
they want is an answer about something
really complicated right bloody now and
you can say all you want about the fact
that women have a difficult time with
that because it's a male dominant
patriarchy any whoo any female lawyer
who's hit 30 and his partner that has
any sense at all knows that's complete
bloody rubbish its market determined
right to the core what happens to the
women when they're in their 30s they all
leave the high-end law firms why because
who in their right mind would want to
live like that that's the issue right
once you make about $60,000 a year for
your family but let's say for you
personally additional income makes zero
have zero impact on your quality of life
zero so why work 80 hours a week well
men will do it some men very few a
handful of hyper-competitive men who are
obsessed with hitting the pinnacle of
the given dominance hierarchy therein
will happily work 80 hours a week and
they'll forego everything else
relationships family children way in the
second category
and so those men are often very
difficult to live with - because they're
so obsessed with their career it's hard
to have a relationship with them and
maybe they don't have much of a
relationship with their kids but they're
damn good at what they do
part of that is is they're smart and
disciplined and they'll work non-stop
all the time it's like an obsession and
that's the sort of people who run things
those are the people who run things well
they're often also disagreeable too
because you want to be rather manage
people really then I'm going to like you
you know when it's not an easy thing to
not be liked and actually if you're an
agreeable person and women are more
agreeable than men it's quite painful to
be disliked but if you're in a
managerial in an executive position the
probability that people are going to
like you is quite low now if you're a
real son of a bitch then they're going
to dislike you more but it's it's those
sit those positions are very stressful
partly because of the interpersonal
dynamics and they're also incredibly
incredibly competitive so the women hit
that at 30 and they're completely
qualified in the law firms are bloody
desperate to keep them because it's
really hard to find highly qualified
people especially once you put all that
time into training especially if they're
also good at bringing in business the
law firms trip over themselves to try to
keep them account the women think why in
the world am i doing this why win the
world would anyone in their right mind
do this especially because they're often
married by that point to and generally
they've married a husband who makes as
much money or more than them so don't
need the damn money and so they think
well there's more to life than this
which is exactly the right thing to
think and so then they go and find a job
that's 9:00 to 5:00 and controllable so
that they can hire a nanny and have some
kids and have a life and it's like yes
that's the intelligent thing to do so
we've got things backwards in our
culture we're thinking at least in part
why aren't there more women in positions
of power wrong question
the right question is why are there any
men at all who want those positions of
power because it's not just positions of
power you have to be such a not head to
think that oh it's a position of power
it's like sure but it's a position of
overwhelming responsibility and if you
make mistakes and you're done right it's
not like you occupy that position of
power and everyone does what they're
told all the time in your life is easy
it's like forget about that people are
on your case to do exactly the right
thing all the time 100% of the time and
maybe you want that maybe
don't so the what I don't know what
people think these people are all
sitting in their offices with their like
feet up on the desk smoking cigars and
oppressing the world it's like that
isn't how it works those people they
work flat out all the time so and it's
fine if that's what you want and some
people are like that they're hyper
industrious people right from a trade
perspective no matter where you put them
you put them in a forest with an axe
they just wander around chopping down
trees non-stop right cuz they're it's
built into them but if you want to have
a balanced life and you should want that
you know because the other thing you'll
find this is God's gospel truth is that
the older you get if you have any sense
at all the more important your family is
to you like that the utility of your
career maybe that Peaks around 35 or 40
and it starts to decline pretty rapidly
after that and what happens if you're
fortunate you have someone in your life
that you love that you wove in yourself
together with and you have some kids so
that you have something to do from the
time you're 50 till the time you're 80
and so it's a real mistake it's a barren
future without children man I can tell
you that it's a real mistake and so we
do a terrible job of say putting that
image forward and saying well yeah now
you know because women have access to
the birth control pill now and can
compete in the same domains as men
roughly speaking there is a real
practical problem here it's partly an
economic problem now because when I was
roughly your age it was still possible
for a one income family to exist well
you know that wages have been flat
except in the upper 1% since 1973 why
well it's easy what happens when you
double the labor force what happens you
have the value of labour so now we're in
a situation where it takes two people to
make as much as one did before so we
went from a situation where women's
career opportunities were relatively
limited to where they were relatively
unlimited and there were two incomes to
wear and so women could work to a
situation where women have to work and
they only make half as much as they
would have otherwise and now we're going
to go into a situation this is the next
step
whereas women will work because men
won't
and that's what's coming now so we there
is an economics economist article
showing that 50% now of boys in school
are having trouble with their basic
subjects and you look around you in
universities you can see this happening
I've watched it over decades I would say
90% of the people in my personality
class are now women there will be a damn
man left in university in ten years
accepted in the STEM fields and it's a
complete bloody catastrophe and it's a
catastrophe for women because I don't
know where the hell you're going to find
someone to to have a you know to marry
and have a family with if this keeps
happening so and you think when you're
19 because you're so clueless when
you're 19 you don't know a bloody thing
you think well I'm not really sure I
want children anyways it's like oh yeah
you tell how well you've been educated
Jesus dismal dismal without fail I got
to tell you without fail I've watched
women go through their professional
careers many many of them it's a very
rare woman who at the age of 30 doesn't
consider having a child her primary
desire and the ones that don't consider
that generally in my observation there's
something that isn't quite right in the
way that they're constituted or looking
at the world sometimes you get women who
are truly non maternal you know by
temperament their did they have a
masculine temper disagreeable they're
not they're not particularly
compassionate they're not maternal they
don't really they're not that interested
in kids fair enough man but there aren't
that many of them and there's plenty who
will not admit to themselves that that's
what they most desperately want do you
think women will be better off if you
hit earlier books go through your
favorite three ah who knows like it's
like it really is a problem now it's a
really tough one I don't think anybody
knows the answer to that because yeah
then you can go
remember well Lord's eating that way
yeah they happen to through your
president find a really dumb kid yeah I
I can't answer that because I've seen
women do a good job of it both both ways
and you did get the odd woman who
manages a high-powered career and kids
but Jesus those women man like they they
they buy more powerful microwaves
because it'll take 45 seconds to cook
the food instead of a minute and I'm not
kidding it's like they're leather up at
five they exercise for half an hour they
make breakfast they get their kids ready
to work they go to work they work 14
hours at 14-hour days flat bloody out
they come home and work for another two
hours to get their kids organized they
have a nanny to help them out then they
work for two more hours before they go
to bed at like 1:00 and then they're up
at 5:00 and they do that again and I'll
tell you you better be tough if you're
going to do that physically too because
you'll just burn yourself to a crisp
I've seen some women manage it you know
but they're like they're tough and
they're rare because that's a hell of a
hell of a regimen and then if anything
goes wrong you know you have a sick kid
or something like that or there's any
sort of crisis in your family it's just
you know it's then it becomes too much
and I don't know the answer to that you
know I mean the advantage women have is
they live about eight years longer than
men because testosterone kills men so
well that that that's right they pay
upfront and gain on on the on in the
long run but how it isn't clear how our
society should sort this out we don't
know and it's partly we don't know what
to do now that women have control of the
reproductive function it's a big mystery
yep
but I think from a conical a spectacle
we'll then were to enter the workforce
later on the competition with people who
remember and I'm always a conflict in
the workforce that people are always
hiring younger talent you can know how
yeah yes well and the thing is young
stupid people have the advantage of
being young middle-aged stupid people
have the disadvantage of being
middle-aged and so if you're going to
hire a young stupid person or a malade
stupid person you'll go for the young
stupid person and I'm by stupid I mean
you know not exciting sarcastic
obviously but I mean without it without
experience and just getting started in
the world you're much more likely to
favor someone young because there's an
instant explanation for their relative
cluelessness and it's a problem you know
so so I don't know what the answer is
but one one answer certainly is at least
in part is to start letting young women
know what being thirty and being female
is like because and also to disabuse
them of the notion that there's
something magical about a career first
of all most people don't have careers
man they have jobs and the reason you
get paid for a job is because your being
has to do things you wouldn't do unless
you were being paid and so it's not it's
not some it's not some utopia of cigar
smoking with your boots up on your desk
that's for sure not thought that that
would be such a utopia to begin with